non je les connais
je vous remercie un bravo tu nous a bien
laissé tomber je pensais que tu pensais
surtout à son scoop un nouveau scoop
pour scouting
voilà c'est mon cursus dingue tellement
pas à 10 dont je t'ai entendu 1-1 par
aux clubs de sport il emmènera pas bien
loin tonga si c'est la gonflette que tu
aimes je peux le faire aussi
ta gueule mongai s'appelle teddy et
navid
il va nous aider parce que si je compte
sur toi pour retrouver chanter n'ya que
suis pas très bien barré
[Musique]
m
jamais je ne veux pas m'en prend pas le
temps d'être inutile
un cap important de coupe-coupe été
au début nous tirent dessus la débâcle
course
comme elle continue on arrive avec ses
côtes bonjour
enfin
[Musique]
partout
à la jav est entendu là en petits
couinements exactement un petit coup de
main qui vient de la bruine mon labo
mais cette dame microtca bacon oui je me
tue à lui dire acquis à l'hôtel à
l'hôtel où je me tue à le dire à l'hôtel
et il avait aussi un jeune homme parce
que là au bout d'un moment moi je vais
faire virer quelqu'un du personnel avec
ces écureuils aurait qui surgissent
données moteur
attention
[Musique]
bien sûr les messieurs
e.on et où j'ai bien dit moi je suis
allergique aux acariens
mais tout ça là devant vous c'est pas
flagrant c'est le comte je ne me suis
pas présentée je suis fantasio grand
reporter au journal moustiques enfin
presque
aujourd'hui mon garçon qui s'est mal
très bizarre de parler à quelqu'un qui
est pas là mais nick et la bonne on voit
alors je n'ose pas et en même temps
j'ose vue je vous ai sorti des griffes
de zorglub vieux ce pont était là je
voulais vous demander une interview je
peux je pense que c'est le jour où je
t'ai fait renvoyer de l'université
c'était le bon temps et je ne vous en
remercierai jamais assez vous savez s'il
était resté à vos côtés je fais encore
un petit assistant alors que maintenant
il ne peut toujours pas de passer deux
mois un beurre vous devez mourir de faim
haute fatigue pas non non je te donnerai
jamais ma formule des champignons dans
les orgues dont la maintenance
champignons de danse est une marque
déposée g que j'y tiens beaucoup à des
champignons
merci au klube à l'époque j'avais
inventé pour réguler la prolifération
des rats arrêtez pas cetera je vois tu
parles toujours à l'envers la moindre
contrariété parce qu'elle est toujours
dit tu es beaucoup trop brouillon et
émotif pour faire un vrai scientifique
je suis pas bouillon je suis pas
bouillon d'accord que tu traites et mac
à la main à bassa évêques à bacau malka
a three card and carry calme très calme
et aujourd'hui cabinet s'attend tué
calme
pas commun donnez moi votre formule et
je vous obtiendrez le titre les
meilleurs scientifiques du deuxième
meilleur scientifiques de la planète
maudite mondiale j'adore ça je vais te
dire la science ça sert à soulager
d'humanité de ces fléaux et toi tu es un
fléau qui veut te soulager sur
l'humanité donc c'est non c'est non non
non non non je vous ai accueilli comme
un ami je vous ai fait préparer vos
petits plats préférés
je voulais demander poliment alors voilà
c'est la formule je vois que lui dis toi
même c'est la mienne est comme vous
voulez mais moi je peux pas la laisser
beaucoup de monde donc ça sert à rien de
foncer dans le tas il faut le plein si
je veux dire non si vous venez de dire
il nous faut un plan où poussent des
flous il nous faut par rapport à cette
vision
[Musique]
surtout les mois de
alors qu'est ce qu'on dit
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
je comprends mal j'avais mon brevet
d'état je suis sûr qu'ils doivent être
coupés nord
[Musique]
à côté
non